the problem with that is oftentimes the
female voter you know you talk about
these Suburban moms that couldn't stand
Donald Trump they're very emotional
voters oftentimes so they don't like his
Twitter feed they don't like his
delivery they focus on things that media
upplays then oh Donald Trump's a bad man
he's not nice he's not kind he's not
this or that and for some reason that
winds up taking priority over those
safety issues over those crime issues so
my concern is Are We Now emotionally
manipulated by media allowing that to be
the case in large part by the way women
female voters are consistently a problem
it's just a fact they will consistently
vote Democrat even though those issues
don't serve them well because they've
been emotionally manipulated by media to
believe that Republicans are just bad
people they're not nice you wouldn't
want to have a beer with them ridiculous
nonsense so I look at the next election
and I say is this going to happen again
are female voters now these Suburban
moms going to step up and vote based on
issues and vote a Rhonda santosin or a
trump someone like that in or are they
going to now be told that Ron DeSantis
is a bad man and they're going to buy
the story and we're all going to be up
shit's creek what do you say to that so
so here's the other problem that we have
and this is more on the Republican side
that the problems Independence on
Republicans have this challenge
they want to change they think they have
to change everyone's mind for their
policies to advance you don't need
everybody so forget about the 47 percent
the 46 and the 44 44 is going to vote
Republican no matter what 46 percent is
going to vote Democrat no matter what
let's set those two aside right so that
leaves us with give or take 10 that
we're dealing with okay 10 or 12 we're
dealing with that 10 to 12 runs America
the 10 or 12 percent that says you know
what I can't vote for Biden anymore I
just can't I'm going to vote for
DeSantis I can't vote for Trump I'm
going to vote for Biden it's that 10 12
that runs America it's not the 44. it's
not the 46's to 10 to 12. so the more
the 10 or 12 says I'm sick of it and I'm
like for example Joe Rogan is not part
of 46 or 44 right Elon Musk is not part
of 46 or 44. they were in the 10 or 12
and they went to 44. 44 is what
Republicans yeah so there's a lot of of
people on the middle now you you mean
Joe Rogan brings in Aaron Rodgers on his
podcast and says and Roger says what's
the solution he says vote Republican and
Roger starts laughing meaning the first
initial reaction of uh Aaron Rodgers is
to laugh if he wasn't in agreement he
would have said what right because he's
against it but if Aaron Rodgers left
what is he saying he's going to vote
Republican so musk says vote Republican
Rogan says vote Republican musk's got
100 million followers on Twitter give or
take Rogan's got God knows how many
followers he's got you can't lose those
people so sometimes we think like they
asked Castro if you have to do the
movement all over again how many
thousands of people would you have
needed to be on your side to make your
Revolution a reality again he says One
True Believer that's all I need you
don't need everybody so if you have Elon
Musk is a True Believer you lose him you
lose tens of millions of votes
potentially you lose Rogan you got to
listen to that guy three four times a
week so I know I know a lot like for
example I run a sales organization right
and many times in sales organization you
sit there and you're thinking I gotta
convince everybody to sell this product
and I got to convince everybody to do it
I got to convince 100 of my sales force
you need one person that buys in who's
got influence and people follow him
that's all you got to do so if you ever
want to move a sales organization find
out who's got the most influence
convince him or heard what product to
sell if she or he sells it other people
are going to follow so that person today
is musk that person today is broken and
they're flipping that's a scary sight on
the other side that's not a good thing
so no it's not there's going to be more
likely there's going to be more like and
by the way there's been more like that
that we just don't know about I'm still
worried about the the Suburban moms and
I just I I too many were lost
based on emotion and I I think that
descent I don't I don't because I think
what's going to happen with DeSantis is
the media is going to use the same
Playbook they did with Trump DeSantis
has been vilified as some sort of devil
and it's really just going to depend on
do these moms prioritize issues that
really relate to their kids do they
prioritize safety do they prioritize
Freedom do they prioritize you know
living in a place that's not you know
increasingly crime infested do they care
about these things more than they care
about their own emotional reaction to a
political candidate because they will
get that same emotional reaction to
DeSantis that they got to Trump the
media will guarantee it so it's just a
question are they strong enough and
strong-willed enough to say maybe
personally I wouldn't want to sit and
have dinner with him but who cares who
cares I need someone who's going to
efficiently get this country back on
track I think that is what remains to be
seen if you want to watch the full
episode you're going to click right here
and if you want to ask me a question one
on one you want to do a one-on-one
FaceTime with a group of your friends
whatever you want you need to download
minute right now click right here and
let's get talking
[Music]